[Musique]
approchez approchez de refuser d une
ligne des pièces d'extraordinaire des
trésors de votre histoire à chaque unité
sa pépite direction laurie parmi les
quêtes minet référence de ce musée dédié
au petit train une micheline sa
particularité se trouve dans ses roues
en pneus michelin
le chef d'entreprise a souhaité
fabriquer ce pneu rails pour le confort
des voyageurs ici ce train jouir
présente un prototype son modèle final à
quelques très différents
l'ami fine en 1931 relie paris deauville
en 2h03 ça paraît un peu comme ça très
précis et très cadré mais en fait elle
bat de 32 minutes le record de la vapeur
d'ailleurs il ya les journaux en ont
parlé
c'est un peu le la course entre david et
goliath david lammy fines gaules y est
le gros la grosse mastodontes de la
vapeur mesdames et messieurs restons
dans le joint est partout à la fois
après trois ans de fermeture pour
rénovation le musée du jouet a rouvert
ses portes en mai dernier
il retrace l'histoire de ses compagnons
de notre enfance en commençant dès
l'antiquité
grâce à un dépôt du musée du louvre nous
avons déjà là des poupées
nous avons une toupie des osselets nous
avons des hochets pour les tout petits
et puis même un jouet avec des petites
rule qui était attirée le tout étant
introduit par un panneau de sarcophage
sans doute d'une sépulture d'enfants
donc c'est un dépôt d'objets magnifiques
et d'une grande ancienneté et nous
sommes particulièrement fiers et touché
par la confiance du musée du louvre et
indiana jones les trésors d'egypte
pensez à faire un tour du côté du
château de dampierre le domaine dont le
parc a rouvert au printemps sort de ces
hangars les calèches de la famille de
luynes pour une première présentation
avant la création d'un musée dédié
parmi ce parc hippomobile une calèche de
gala cette calèche a été l'occasion lors
du mariage famille d'uzès avec la
famille de luynes d'un grand mariage
amis d'uzès évidemment avec la duchesse
d'uzès qui était très connu dans les
yvelines et donc pour ce mariage sa
fille avec un duc de luynes et biens
partent sur paris pour remonter les
champs elysées passe par la cour
d'elysée justement du palais
présidentiel pour présenter aux prises
la république nous avons aussi ici la
marque de carrossier donc morel à paris
et celui-là c'est numéro 15 162 quittons
la route et les chevaux pour les fleuves
au musée de la batellerie deux couples
ont fait un tonneau
le conservateur sort de sa vitrine des
objets rares fraîchement confié au musée
par les descendants de son auteur
j'adore ce petit avion ils sont l'oeuvre
de jean jourdain rentrée en centres
d'apprentissage dans une usine de
chaudronnerie à l'âge de 12 ans dans le
cadre de ses études il fabrique ce globe
et cet avion avant de passer héros
scaphandre quand il a dû trouver du
travail
il a décidé de créer une société pour
fabriquer du matériel pour ce calendrier
et il a fabriqué des casques réel donc
on en a ici un modèle de sa main
également donc imaginer fabriquer tout
ça avec des systèmes de martelage et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il s'est lancé dans
cette production
parce que au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale avec toutes les
destructions tous les bateaux coulés
dans les ports fluviaux toutes les mines
qui avaient été laissées par les
allemands il y avait énormément de
travail il a fallu recruter former
énormément de scaphandrier ce modèle
intacte n'a pas servi un scaphandrier il
est la dernière création de l'artisan
avant de donner les clés de son atelier
un souvenir qui l'a accompagné dans son
salon jusqu'à la fin de sa vie